well I think probably the earliest
theater was musical um when they talk
about Western theater coming out of
Greek religious performance the
dithyramb the bach 'ok you know rights
and that was movement and music oriented
and singing and so I don't you know
since then it may be started to codify a
little bit in 20th century of what a
musical was supposed to be which in
terms of the kind of music and the
subjects of the stories but anything
that uses songs I mean as opera which
tends to be you know all song but a
musical tends to be the story that uses
songs to propel the plot and evoke
emotion and help the story in a way that
straight played does in a different
different way so I remember seeing a
Robert Wilson piece that he did with Tom
Waits and William Burroughs called the
black writer which was very you know as
far from her Broadway musical as you
could think but it had dialogue it had
musical at songs it had a linear
somewhat linear narrative and it was I
realized this was a musical you know we
were inspired by that inspired by
something a little bit less linear like
Sandra Bernhardt's without you or
nothing and you know Ziggy Stardust
Tommy which are much listening linear
narratives but have kind of a song cycle
feeling about them and definitely from
Broadway which is you know much more
linear narrative which I prefer and or
traditional NER necessarily linear
um with the beginning middle and end and
the you know the importance of arrival
you know some people like stories to
meander and can just sort of you know
reflect when there's a pretty image
happening and I really need an
escalating story doesn't have to be fast
isn't it to be slow but I need something
going somewhere and arriving somewhere
not that the arrival has to be you know
all loose ends tied up but something
that's that's using metaphor is
extending them at a 4 that's a you know
about something that's investigating
things that that confound us that
interest us that and ultimately try to
be productive or useful to the audience
you know not just a jerk off though I
mean watching some a jerk off can be
useful but not everybody and there's a
sense of um you know trying to figure
things out to make things better maybe
that's just my utilitarian kind of
Catholic thing is good works but to me
the stuff I have that I'm involved with
has to be useful to me but also to an
audience
you know over the top implies it's just
it's too much for what it should be to
me over the top is a pejorative you can
have something extremely heightened and
highly stylized and it's not over the
top because it's exactly what it should
be you know so so and ahead big has
elements that some people would call
over the top but to me are just enough
you know or just right and hectic was a
conscious amalgamation of all elements
of different stage performances
techniques like drag which has a
tradition doesn't necessarily stray
hasn't always necessarily straighten
lately into more serious themes but
certainly Shakespearean and the Greeks
you know it was elements of drag men
playing women kabuki we're serious
themes were examined also stand up stand
up comedy the rock show the punk rock
show the conventions of that performance
art and the well-made play and you know
well made Broadway musical so using
elements of all of those you know and
trying to keep the integrity of all of
them but having to be a whole you know a
holistic kind of entity was our goal and
which meant that the stand up had to be
funny you know the drag had to be you
know using some of the the comedic
double entendre that you might come out
of that rock show the band had to be
there it couldn't be under them back of
the stick let's be up front you know the
this songs had to propel the plot you
know and the characters which is what
Robert musicals do well and so giving
each of the forms their integrity but
also melding them in a way that was new